Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. In Ausgabe 49 dieses Formats blicken wir mal wieder nach Russland und fragen uns, was ist los beim WM-Gastgeber? Wie ist die Stimmung im Land? Das erzählt uns die Journalistin Katrin Scheib hier im Kurzpass. Katrin, schön dich mal wieder zu hören. Hallo.
Hallo Max, hi.
Das ist ja toll, dass wir mal wieder eine Sendung aufnehmen. Meine Hörerinnen und Hörer werden dich hoffentlich schon kennen aus der Folge, die wir kurz vor der WM-Auslosung aufgenommen haben, wo wir ja auch schon deinen Newsletter vorgestellt haben. Und es gibt eine Neuigkeit. Denn wem der wöchentliche Newsletter zu all den Dingen, die so interessant sind, in Russland mit WM-Bezug, wem das zu wenig ist, der kommt jetzt auf seine Kosten und zwar wo.
Das stimmt. Ich mache dir für die Kollegen von ntv.de jetzt einen täglichen WM-Countdown. Es ist ja nun Zielgerade, die letzten 100 Tage bis zum Anpfiff. Und da gibt es so viele Erzählen an kleinen Beobachtungen hier aus dem Alltag oder auch an organisatorischem, oder was ich als Fan tun kann, falls ich nach Russland kommen will, um mich besser vorzubereiten. Ja, die ersten zehn Folgen habe ich jetzt geschrieben. Es läuft ganz gut. Und ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, es wird immer schneller. Es geht immer, immer schneller voran, bis wir dann plötzlich Juni haben.
Ja, das Gefühl teile ich und ebenfalls teile ich auch das Gefühl, diese Masse an Informationen. Also ich habe den Status-Formats mitbekommen und habe da mal für drei Tage nicht mitgelesen. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, was da einfach an jedem Tag zusammenkommt. Und du kannst da ja auch ein bisschen mehr in die Tiefe gehen als im Newsletter. Wirklich interessant, also kann ich nur empfehlen, alle zuhören und hören. Wir werden es natürlich auch verlinken in den Show Notes. So, nachdem wir das letzte Mal vor der WM-Auslösung gesprochen haben, muss ich dir noch eine Frage stellen und zwar zur russischen Gruppe. Denn die ist bemerkenswert leicht. Russland hat eigentlich fast aus jedem Topf den Gegner bekommen, der den niedrigsten FIFA-Koeffizienten hat und spielt jetzt mit Saudi-Arabien, Ägypten und Uruguay in einer Gruppe. Hat denn das, was an der Erwartungshaltung im Land, irgendwas geändert?
Also vielleicht hat es ein ganz klein bisschen die Zahl der Menschen gesteigert, die in extrem optimistischen Momenten glauben, dass Russland über die Gruppenphase hinauskommt. Aber ganz ehrlich, nein, bei aller Unterstützung für die eigene Nationalmannschaft, ich erlebe das ja eigentlich, dass die Leute sehr realistisch sind. Die können auch, wie du sagst, auf die FIFA-Liste gucken, schauen, wo Russland da steht und sich dann ausrechnen, wie viel daran so Sachen wie Heimvorteil noch ändern können. Also ich glaube, das Bewusstsein ist da, dass das eine leichte Gruppe ist, der glaube, dass das so richtig viel verändert, eher nicht. Du kriegst relativ viele Witzchen so, dass es die Ölgruppe ist. Ja klar. Zwischen den beiden großen ölfördernden Nationen. Also hier und da Erdölwitzchen, das ist das, was sich geändert hat.
Jetzt, als ich die Auslosen mitverfolgt habe, ich hatte so ein gewisses Geschmäckle im Mund. Ich dachte mir so, das trifft sich ja jetzt irgendwie alles sehr, sehr gut. Und natürlich ist das rein theoretisch möglich, dass das jetzt alles Zufall war, aber es könnte auch sein, dass man da irgendwelchen Verschwörungstheorien erliegt. Gibt es denn diese Diskussion in Russland auch?
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen. Also ich glaube auch, ehrlich gesagt, also so eine gewisse gesunde Selbstironie ist hier eh vorhanden. So ein, ja, wir wissen, wie gut oder wie schlecht unsere Mannschaft ist. Also solche Theorien habe ich nicht gesehen, halte ich für halbwegs absurd. Also sind mir in der Deutung hier nicht begegnet.
Nein, keine angewärmten Kugeln und so weiter. Das ist ja auch irgendwie mag man sich ja auch nicht vorstellen.
Ich meine, ein Termin im Dezember in Moskau, wir haben jetzt hier gefühlte sechs Monate Schnee liegen. Ich bin tendenziell total für alles, was mit Anwärmen zu tun hat. Ich glaube nur, dass in dem Fall nicht stattgefunden hat.
Oh ja, das glaube ich gut und gerne. Wir Deutschen haben ja schon, ich sage jetzt einfach mal, wir Deutschen meinen damit eigentlich erst mal nur mich. Wir haben ja schon gejammert über den Winter hier in München. Jetzt in meinem Fall, wie lange der ging und wie grau er war und wie kalt er war. Und da will ich das nicht in Vergleich setzen zu dem, was du gerade.
Ja, ihr habt ganz furchtbar gelitten und ich vielen Dank auch für den Begriff Russenpeitsche. Der hat uns ja alle sehr gefreut.
Hat es dir ja bis nach Russland geschafft. Das ist mir fast ein bisschen unangenehm. So tut man schon viel für die Völkerverständigung. Aber lasst uns zurückkommen zum Fußball. Beziehungsweise ja die Frage ist, wie sehr eigentlich zum Fußball. Ich würde gerne mit dir noch mal kurz über Vitaly Mutko sprechen, über den haben wir schon in der letzten Kurzpassfolge gemeinsam gesprochen. Das ist der russische Sportminister und gleichzeitig Präsident des russischen Fußballverbandes. Und er steckt knietief, naja, vielleicht sogar halbstief drin in den Dopingvorwürfen, die es gibt rund um die Winterspiele in Sochi. Und wenn ich gesagt habe, er ist Präsident des russischen Fußballverbandes und russischer Sportminister, dann ist genau das falsch. Denn das hat sich geändert.
Das stimmt.
Er war bald das.
Das ist der Zwischengrätschen. Genau. Da wollte ich dich so taktvoll ausreden lassen, aber jetzt korrigierst du dich schon selbst. Ja, das stimmt. Ja, Vitaly Mutko war lange so fast das Gesicht der WM oder der WM-Vorbereitung. Aber je länger die Geschichte sich zog, je klarer, je mehr es Hinweise gab, dass er in dieser ganzen Nummer rund um Sochi systematisches, staatlich unterstütztes Doping drinsteckt, desto mehr seiner Jobs musste er abgeben. Mal lässt er ihn in Ruhe, mal ist er wirklich zurückgetreten. Aber das ist inzwischen eine lange Liste von Sachen, die er nicht mehr isst. Das ist so der XXX.
Ja, das kann ich dir empfehlen, das ist auch Teil deines WM-Countdowns gewesen. Das ist eine sehr lustige Liste, aber ich will jetzt da die Pointen nicht vorwegnehmen. Da sollen die Hörerinnen und Hörer nochmal selber sich das in Ruhe zu Gemüte führen. Wie wird denn das innerhalb von Russland aufgenommen? Denn wir wissen ja schon, von diesem systematischen Doping, da hält zumindest Vladimir Putin und alle beteiligten Akteure gar nichts und sagen, das ist eher eine Verschwörung des Westens. Ich denke, die Hörerinnen und Hörer werden auch ein bisschen mitverfolgt haben, wie es rund um die aktuellen Winterspiele lief. Wie wird denn das wahrgenommen, dass Mutgo da jetzt einen Job nach dem anderen und letztlich ja eigentlich jetzt alle Verantwortlichkeiten, die er rund um die Weltmeisterschaft hatte, abgeben musste?
Ja, ich glaube, die Deutung ist relativ klar, die WM ist ein wichtiges Renommierprojekt. Da nimmt man Mutgo halt aus der Schusslinie, sodass man sich diese Debatten halt in den Monaten vor der WM erspart. Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass der weg vom Fenster ist. Der ist aus russischer Perspektive, ist das ein verdienter Mann, der hat an vielen Stellen Verantwortung übernommen. Er war jetzt nicht so der klassische Kandidat für, wir machen Ämter-Trennung wie bei den Grünen. Es war deutlich eher so viel Macht in zwei Händen, aber der ist jetzt mal ein paar Monate irgendwo geparkt, hat demonstrativ alles abgegeben, was zu tun hat mit WM. Aber das heißt nicht, dass der Mann keine Macht mehr hat oder das nicht ab 15., 16. Juli wieder mehr von ihm hören, vielleicht dann in einer anderen Aufgabe.
Und ist er dann das Opfer in der Darstellung der Medien oder ist er ein Held, weil er freiwillig zurücktritt oder wie?
So offensiv Deutung findest du hier sowieso ganz wenig. Es ist mehr so, bitte gehen Sie weiter, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen. Zum Beispiel hier TASC, die staatliche Nachrichtenagentur, die dann einfach sehr als normalstes Ding der Welt das alles berichtet und der gibt diese Aufgabe ab und das war ja ein bisschen viel und das macht jetzt der und der möchte sich mehr auf das konzentrieren, das ist also komplett. Es ist eigentlich der Ton eher Business as Usual, es ist halt Organisation, es ist ein großes Event und da helfen viele Leute mit.
Okay, apropos gehen Sie weiter, es gibt hier nichts zu sehen. Du hast etwas gesehen, wo man eigentlich nicht mal so richtig weitergehen kann. Du bist zufällig auf ein 21 Seiten langes Dokument mit mehr als 400 Namen gestoßen und das sind alle Russen, denen ein Gericht verboten hat, zu Sportveranstaltungen zu kommen, inklusive der Spiele der Weltmeisterschaft, zumindest bei den meisten und da stand alles drin. Klar Name, Vorname, Nachname, welches Gericht die Entscheidung getroffen hat, wie lange die Sperre ausgesprochen wurde. Wie bist du denn da überhaupt drauf gekommen?
Total zufällig. Ich wollte eigentlich ein Stück darüber schreiben, wie das funktioniert. Du musst dich ja, wenn du als Ausländer nach Russland einreist und länger als sieben Werktage bleibst, hier bei den Behörden registrieren. Das System gab es zum Beispiel auch in der DDR. Du musstest dich bei der Polizei melden, wenn du da ins Land gereist bist und Freunde besucht hast. Und ich wollte dazu eigentlich so ein Detail nachlesen, weil während des Confed-Cups haben sie die Fristen verkürzt, da musste man sich schon an einen Tag melden. Ich habe versucht, herauszufinden, ob das bei der WM auch so wird. Jedenfalls habe ich auf der Seite vom Innenministerium rumgelesen und wie das dann so ist. Du kommst von Hölzchen auf Stöckchen und in so einem Bereich mit irgendwelchen Downloadlinks stand dann halt diese Liste. Und man muss schon sagen, ich hatte die so detailliert noch nicht gesehen. Ich habe dazu auch bis jetzt wenig Berichterstattung gesehen. Aber dass es diese Liste gibt, ist kein Geheimnis. Es ist jetzt nicht, dass ich irgendwelche Top Secret Dokumente entdeckt habe überhaupt. Ich hatte mehr so den Eindruck, ich glaube halt für russische Medien, weil hier im Land der Umgang mit Datenschutzen ganz anders ist, hat das nicht so Empörpotenzial, wie das bei mir sofort diesen Reflex ausgelöst hat, was da eigentlich alles preisgegeben wird an Daten. Ich hatte das Gefühl, so detailliert aufgeschrieben habe ich das noch nicht gesehen. Das war vielleicht eher der Unterschied. Denn keiner möchte sagen, der arme Hooligan braucht auf jeden Fall nur liebevolle Betreuung und alles wird gut.
Klar, aber muss sein Name auf der Internet zu lesen sein.
Genau, auf so einer langen Skala von wo sind die Rechte von normalen Stadionbesuchern, die ein sicheres Spiel erleben wollen und wo sind die Rechte von jemandem, der dort mal auffällig geworden ist durch Gewalt oder was ähnliches, halt nicht sein Leben lang für alle, die ihn kennen, als genau dieser Typ identifizierbar zu sein. Also überleg mal in Deutschland, wie es ist, wie weit das Recht geht, keine identifizierende Berichterstattung über dich zu haben, bei sehr viel schwereren Vergehen als Hooliganismus, ohne den klein spielen zu wollen. Aber das ist hier im Land, wird hier sehr anders gesehen, und du erwartest schon die kompletten Namen. Und das ist ja in Russland nicht nur Vornamen und Nachnamen, es gibt ja hier noch den sogenannten Vatersnamen, also so Vladimir Vladimirovich. Das ist also...
Das macht die russischen Romane immer so unläsbar.
Ja, genau. Aber es ist halt noch ein Detail, das noch klarer wird, welcher du denn bist. Also selbst wenn jemand vielleicht den gleichen Vornamen hat, ist es unwahrscheinlich, dass er auch noch den gleichen Vatersnamen hat. Es steht drin, wann du geboren bist, wo, welches Gericht dich verurteilt hat, es ist extrem detailliert. Und natürlich habe ich mir dann den Spaß gemacht, bei jemandem zu schauen, der einen ungewöhnlichen Namen hatte. Und natürlich kannst du ohne Ende Sachen über den rausfinden. Also wo der lebt, wo der studiert hat, was der für Hobbys hat, was der für ein Musikinstrument spielt. Also das ist ein massiver Eingriff in die Privatsphäre.
Wahnsinn. Ich stelle mir nur vor, die berühmte Gewalttäter-Sportdatei, die es ja auch in Deutschland gibt, mit sehr, sehr vielen Einträgen, wäre öffentlich verfügbar. Man will sich gar nicht ausdenken, was das für die einzelnen Leute bedeutet. Und du hast, die ist ja schon richtig eingeordnet. Natürlich, die haben sich auch alle was zu Schulden kommen lassen. Aber ich fand es einfach bemerkenswert. Und auch, dass du sagst, das ist jetzt kein Thema, was dann in russischen Medien so groß ein Empörungspotenzial hätte.
Nee, weil hier halt die Vorstellung, was Privatsphäre ist und leistet, welche Persönlichkeitsrechte du hast gegenüber dem Staat, da verlaufen die Grenzen in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung komplett anders. Für mich war halt der erste Impuls, also wenn ich möchte, dass jemand dauerhaft hooligan bleibt, dann tue ich das doch am besten, indem ich den so oute, dass absolut sein komplettes Familien- und Freundesumfeld das weiß und sich im Zweifel von ihm abwendet und nur die Leute sich noch für ihn interessieren, die seine Mithooligen sind. Also das scheint mir ein relativ einfacher Mechanismus zu sein, dass so eine Art, das nach außen zu kommunizieren, nach hinten losgehen muss.
Absolut. Wie ist denn das Thema Hooliganismus jetzt mit Bezug auf die WM? Steht da zu befürchten, dass es zur Ausschreitung kommt oder kann man das erwarten, was auch schon rund um die EM in Frankreich so ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen kommuniziert wurde, à la, naja, die russischen Hooligans hätten sich da noch mal ausgetobt, womit ich das jetzt aber nicht euphemisieren möchte, weil man eben im eigenen Land sich sowas nicht leisten könne?
Also, natürlich bin ich keine Hooligan-Expertin, ich habe keine Szenekontakte, ich kann auch nur lesen, was andere lesen oder halt wiedergeben, wie ich es im Land erlebe. Wir hatten den Confed Cup letzten Sommer als kleine Proberunde und da konntest du auf jeden Fall beobachten, wie deutlich und demonstrativ hier Sicherheit stattfindet, Polizeipräsenz, auch Präsenz von Leuten, die nicht, die sind von der persönlichen Inszenierung nicht Freund und Helfer, sondern die sind erkennbar in der Spezialmontur mit Schild, mit Helm, mit Schlagstock. Also es ist eine ganz andere Art, demonstrativ zu präsentieren, wir sind hier anwesend, viel berittene Polizei auch und so. Das ist aber auch nicht Confed Cup spezifisch. Du siehst auch extrem viel Security bei russischen Liga-Spielen, je nachdem, wer da gegeneinander spielt. Es ist ein autoritär regiertes Land und diese Art von Demonstration von Stabilität durch Polizeipräsenz, das ist hier was, das ist lange eingeübt. Insofern, natürlich kann ich nicht sagen, bei der WM wird jedes Spiel komplett ohne Vorfälle bleiben. Ich glaube aber schon alleine, um das, nicht nur um die Sicherheit der Fans zu gewährleisten, sondern natürlich auch, weil es fatal wäre für das Image von Russland, glaube ich, dass da sehr viel Personalpräsenz, Zeit, Geld investiert wird für sehr demonstrative Sicherheit.
Es wäre ja nur logisch, trotzdem interessant, dass das viele der Themen sind, mit denen nicht nur du dich beschäftigst, sondern auch andere Artikel, die über die WM in Russland vorausblicken. Es wird eigentlich weniger über die Stimmung im Land geschrieben, auch erstaunlich wenig, finde ich, darüber, ob jetzt die Stadien fertig werden. Das ist ja, gerade Deutschen ist das immer so ganz wichtig, schaffen sie es dann rechtzeitig, weil wir waren ja so früh dran damals, 2006. Also das ist jetzt meine Interpretation, warum wir Deutschen daran so interessiert sind, aber das findet man viel. Aber auch noch die anderen Themen, die ich so wahrgenommen habe in den letzten Wochen, das sind immer richtige Klopper. Also wir haben jetzt schon über Hooliganismus gesprochen, wir haben schon Mutko und das ganze staatliche Doping-Thema mal kurz angesprochen. Und dann haben wir noch den Themenkomplex, der auch bei dir wieder aufgeworfen wurde, zum einen der Homophobie und des Rassismus, der ja in Russland auch noch mal auf eine andere Art und Weise stattfindet, als vielleicht in vielen anderen Ländern. Glaubst du denn, das wird sich auf das Turnier auch auswirken?
Also vielleicht zwei Sachen. Zum einen, was du sagst, die Berichterstattung und solche Themen. Ich glaube, das sind natürlich und vor allen Dingen halt so so ein Zeitpunkt. Wir haben jetzt Mitte März. Ich glaube, das ist so eine Phase, wo jetzt war gerade noch mal die neue Ticket-Verkaufsrunde. Das ist jetzt einfach eine Phase, wo viele Leute entscheiden, ob sie da denn hinreisen. Genau. Und ich glaube, das sind schon Anhaltspunkte, auf die Leute gucken. Wenn ich schwul bin und Fußball-Fan, ist das ein Land, wo ich es riskiere, hinzureisen. Natürlich. Wie muss ich mein normales Verhalten vielleicht anpassen? Weil es hier Restriktionen gibt, Diskriminierung, eine Stimmung in der Bevölkerung, die alles andere als freundlich und entgegenkommend ist. Also ich glaube, dass...
Ist das denn auch so? Also kann man das so verallgemeinern sagen?
Also das muss ich nicht verallgemeinern. Da gibt es ja durchaus Umfragen zu. Also wenn du siehst, wie viele Fußballfans hier sagen, schwulen Lesben, dem stehe ich nicht positiv gegenüber. Also das ist jetzt eine sehr hochsprachliche Formulierung für eine Stimmung. Natürlich findest du Leute, die sagen, jeder nach seiner Fassung. Es hat sicherlich zum Beispiel geholfen hier. Roman Neustetter hat, war das Anfang dieser Woche oder Ende letzter Woche, ein Interview gegeben und da haben sie ihn auch gefragt, wie er denn dazu steht. Und mit Verlaub, dass man fragen muss, wie jemand dazu steht, ist ja eigentlich schon seltsam. Aber er hat dann eben gesagt, wenn ein Mann einen Mann liebt, dann ist das so und das ist seine Sache und das geht uns nichts an. Und der Mann ist immerhin ein russischer Nationalspieler. Das schadet nicht, wenn der das mal sagt. Und es ist immer noch ein Land, wo solche, wo auch Äußerungen wie, wir sind noch nie Schwule im Fußball begegnet und ich hoffe doch sehr, das bleibt so, hohoho, komplett unsanktioniert von irgendwelchen Trainern gemacht werden können. Natürlich ist das ein Klima, wo man sich dreimal überlegt, ob man dann da hinreisen möchte, auch wenn es genauso gute öffentliche Stellungnahmen gibt, wo Leute sagen, ihr müsst euch alle keine Sorgen machen, es wird keine Sanktionen geben, wenn ihr eine Regenbogenflage dabei habt, es wird keine Sanktionen geben, wenn ihr euch im Stadion küsst. Die Frage ist halt, wer überlegt sich, ob er es drauf ankommen lässt. Und nicht jede Situation, nicht jede Begegnung, die du hier haben wirst, wird in einem offiziellen Rahmen stattfinden.
Genau, ich glaube, das ist der entscheidende Punkt. Und jetzt du ganz persönlich, aufgrund deiner Erfahrung, deiner Zeit jetzt in Russland, würdest du es Leuten empfehlen?
Ich finde das ein bisschen anmaßend. Ich bin in der Gruppe Menschen, die hier extrem privilegiert sind, also weiß, heterosexuell, weiblich. Die Zahl der Fälle, in denen ich hier mit Diskriminierung zu tun habe, sind minimal. Daher finde ich, also einerseits kann ich nur anmaßen, ich kann keinem Schulen-Fan, keinem lesbischen Fan sagen, ja kommt her, wird alles gut. Ich kann sagen, ich lebe jetzt hier vier Jahre, in meinem Freundeskreis sind Leute, die schwul sind, die hier, oder auch lesbisch sind, die hier in Russland gut leben. Also ob sie ihr Leben überall so gestalten können, wie sie das in einem anderen Land täten? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Das heißt, das sind dann oft persönliche Abwägungen. Ich habe hier vielleicht nicht alle Freiheiten, aber mein Partner lebt nun mal hier, oder ich habe hier nicht alle Freiheiten, aber beruflich tut sich für mich hier eine Chance auf. Also die Tatsache, dass du natürlich in diesem Land auch Menschen hast, die schwul, lesbisch sind, die hier gut leben, heißt nicht, dass das eine Garantie ist für jeden in jeder Situation.
Ja, ja gut klar. Die Entscheidung muss ja dann auch jeder für sich selbst treffen. Auf jeden Fall eigentlich ja auch gut, dass im Zuge einer solchen Sportveranstaltung auch nochmal darüber berichtet wird, dass dieses Turnier nicht in einem luftleeren Raum stattfindet, sondern eben in einem autoritär geführten Staat.
Das ist ja immer das Argument für Wandel durch Annäherung und die Frage ist, was ist halt am 16. Juli? Wenn das Turnier durch ist, dann wird es ja eigentlich interessant, wie sieht es dann hier im Land aus mit Rassismus, mit überhaupt Fremdenfeindlichkeit, mit Diskriminierung von Schwulen und Lesben? Hat das, was wir jetzt machen und diese Debatten, die wir jetzt führen und die Tatsache, dass da im Sommer Leute aus aller Herren Länder kommen mit aller Herren Hintergründen und unterschiedlichem Aussehen, hat das irgendeine Wirkung über das Turnier hinaus? Das wird auch interessant.
Ja, da wirst du mir nochmal Rede und Antwort anstehen müssen. Anderes, schweres oder schwieriges Thema, Stichwort Rassismus. Du hast es auch gerade schon gestreift. Ich habe gelesen bei Twitter, ich konnte es allerdings selbst nicht mitverfolgen, dass es jetzt zum Beispiel beim Spiel Zenit St. Petersburg gegen Raba Leipzig auch rassistische Ausserhörungen gegeben hätte. Wie gesagt, mit der Einschränkung, ich habe es jetzt persönlich nicht am Fernseher oder so etwas mitverfolgen können, ich habe es nur bei Twitter vorbei fliegen sehen. Ist denn das auch ein akutes Thema in Russland?
Also, ich habe das Spiel leider auch nicht geguckt, darum kann ich jetzt zu dem konkreten Fall nichts sagen, aber klar ist das eine Baustelle. Also, es werden regelmäßig Strafen verhängt wegen rassistischer Äußerungen, Rufen, Banner, selbst die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, dieser Fall da vor ein paar Wochen, wo bei einem Verein, die waren im Trainingslager irgendwo, wo es warm war, ich weiß leider nicht mehr wo, und dann hat jemand auf dem offiziellen Twitter-Account des Vereins ein Foto gepostet von zwei schwarzen Spielern, die beim Training schwitzen mit irgendeinem dümmlichen Spruch, ha ha, Schokolade schmilzt in der Sonne. Und das war relativ schwer zu vermitteln in der russischen Debatte, warum das rassistisch ist. Weil einfach der Diskurs hier ein anderer ist und weil, also da kamen die klassischen, aber das ist doch nicht schlimm, Schokolade ist doch was nettes, das ist doch durchweg positiv. Also das ist einfach ein Diskurs, der hier auf einem ganz anderen Level stattfindet und wo man eben noch sehr viele Runden drehen muss und sehr oft thematisieren, warum das vielleicht keine gute Idee ist.
Und wird denn dann sowas vom Verband aus sanktioniert, weil du auch von Strafen gesprochen hast?
Ja, in dem Fall hat es tatsächlich Konsequenzen gehabt, also es war bei Spatak und der quasi Preisleiter für Medien oder wir würden sagen für Öffentlichkeitsarbeit hat dann tatsächlich eine Strafe zahlen müssen.
Er persönlich.
Ja, er persönlich und die Strafe hat auch der russische Fußballverband verhängt. Die andere Frage ist dann wieder so eine Strafe, was macht die aus? Also der Mann muss 20.000 Rubel Strafe zahlen, 20.000 Rubel, das sind knapp 300 Euro als jemand, der bei einem großen Moskauer Fußballverein einen exponierten Job hat. Ich glaube davon, da muss er auf kein Restaurant essen für verzichten, also das ist sehr klar nur ein symbolischer Akt, aber es ist immerhin ein symbolischer Akt, also es blieb nicht komplett ohne Reaktion.
Jetzt habe ich bei dir auch gelesen, dass der Run auf WM-Tickets ganz schön groß sein muss. Hast du denn inzwischen eins bekommen?
Boah ja, endlich, aber echt wirklich jetzt auch auf den letzten Pücker. Ich habe in der vorigen Phase, also in der Lotteriephase die Hand gehoben, echt für einige Begegnungen, auch nicht nur Deutschland-Spiele, sondern auch einfach irgendwelche Begegnungen hier in Moskau. Wenn ich schon den Vorteil habe, hier zu leben und einen kurzen Weg habe, dann kann ich mir auch mal ein Spiel anschauen mit einer Mannschaft, die mich sonst vielleicht nicht so interessiert, kann ja trotzdem interessant und atmosphärisch sein. Und dann kamen echt vier Absagen auf vier Lotterieversuche, was auch insofern frustrierend ist, weil irgendwie das Gefühl, der halbe Moskauer Freundeskreis schon weiß, zu welchen Spielen er geht und immer erzählt, ja und wir gehen zu dem, ach da sind wir auch, ach gucken wir, wir sitzen gegenüber, können wir winken und ich sitze da daneben und schweige höflich. Aber jetzt hier bei der First-Come-First-Surf-Runde hat es endlich geklappt. In dem Fall, also ich bin ja mit meinem Mann hier, Markus, und in dem Fall hatten wir beide den ganzen Tag diesen Wartebalken laufen und bei ihm hat es dann irgendwann abends geklappt und ich gehe mal fest davon aus, dass die Tickets, die er gekauft hat, dass ich da die Begleitung bin.
Ja, da werde ich dich dann auch nur mal zu befragen nach dem Spielen.
Ja, das machen wir halt. Also ich gehe davon aus. Wir haben jedenfalls Karten für Südkorea, Deutschland in Kasan und das wird noch richtig spaßig. Gestern wollte ich Unterkunft buchen und es gibt exakt nichts mehr. Also es gibt kein Hotelzimmer mehr, egal auf welcher Plattform du guckst. Ich kenne halt ein Hotel, wo ich schon mal übernachtet habe, es gibt auch da nichts mehr. Die meisten Hostels sind schon voll und bei Airbnb fängst du bei 150 Euro die Nacht an. Also das wird glaube ich so ein Projekt fürs Wochenende da noch irgendwas passendes zu finden.
Und sind das jetzt die letzten Tickets, die vergeben wurden, dass die innerhalb von Russland über die digitale Lagentheke gingen oder gibt es auch noch andere Tickets für Fans aus anderen Ländern, weil die stehen ja dann vor ähnlichen Problemen und haben nicht den Vorteil, dass sie schon mal allein die Sprache kennen und vielleicht den einen oder anderen Trick noch kennen, doch irgendwie eine Unterkunft zu finden.
Ich weiß natürlich nicht, wie sehr oder wie wenig die Hotels mit ihren Kontingenten haushalten. Ob die sagen, wir sind uns so sicher, am 27. Juni kommen zig Leute, die wollen Südkorea gegen Deutschland spielen sehen, da geben wir nicht jetzt schon an, weiß ich nicht, an Booking, an TripAdvisor, an HES unsere Kontingente raus. Das kann natürlich sein. Wie die sich takten, das kann ich nicht einschätzen. Ich kann dir sagen, jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist genau das die Baustelle und ich weiß auch noch nicht so richtig. Also wie gesagt, vielleicht eine Privatunterkunft, wobei man sich ja dann eben umkümmern muss um diese Registrierung. Das ist noch mal eine ganz andere Baustelle oder ich meine, ich kenne auch ein, zwei Leute entfernt in Kasan, aber jetzt nicht so auf dem Level, wo ich sagen würde, hey, hast du eine Couch? Wie sieht es aus? Du kennst mich nicht mehr, aber wir haben uns vor zwei Jahren mal eine halbe Stunde unterhalten. Also da müssen wir mal schauen.
Aber das spricht ja schon mal dafür, Russland eh ein sportbegeistertes Land, aber wir können damit rechnen, auch zu dieser WM werden die Stadien voll mit Fans sein. So hört sich das zumindest an.
Ich gehe davon aus, also gerade auch, weil es beim Confed Cup ja so am Anfang durchaus negative Berichterstattung gab, aber da so viele leere Plätze und dann konntest du ja bei den späteren Spielen sehen, da saßen dann irgendwelche Bambini-Mannschaften oder Russen, die plötzlich mit schwerem Akzent und großer Begeisterung Chile angefeuert haben oder Kamerun oder ich hoffe jetzt hier ist kein Quatsch, aber ich glaube es war Chile und Kamerun, das eine Spiel, was ich mal gesehen habe. Also da wird garantiert für gesorgt. Lustigerweise, ich habe mir neulich einen Stapel alte russische, also eigentlich sowjetische Fußballbücher gekauft auf so dem russischen Gegenstück von Ebay und dann habe ich an einem von denen geblättert und dann hatte der frühere Besitzer da noch Eintrittskarten drin, die liegen von 1980 von der Sommer-Olympiade in Moskau und ich erzähle das deshalb, weil da stand auch unten rechts der Preis drauf und dann war da ein Stempel drauf, 70% ermäßigt. Das heißt auch da haben sie schon darauf geachtet, dass das Stadion nicht leer bleibt bei den Leichtathletik-Veranstaltungen und ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht russlandspezifisch, das ist glaube ich große gute Tradition bei so Großveranstaltungen. Wenn jetzt wirklich sich für eines der obskureren Matches in einem der obskureren Orte an einem Tag, wo vielleicht noch andere Sachen stattfinden.
Bei Regen.
Bei Regen, genau. Wenn sich da dann doch nicht genug Leute finden, die dafür bezahlen, dass sie dann die letzten Tickets doch irgendwie verteilen. Aber im Prinzip, das sah alles schon sehr gut verkauft aus, wobei auch wieder da, du weißt natürlich nicht, ob die FIFA noch irgendwelche Kontingente an Karten zurückhält. Es soll ja noch, glaube ich, eine Freiverkaufsphase geben, die theoretisch, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, bis während des Turniers läuft. Ob man da noch irgendwelche Chancen hat. Vielleicht sind das dann auch zurückgegebene Karten.
Ja, könnte natürlich sein. Also relativ kurzfristig findet man dann doch immer noch was. So habe ich es zumindest bei vergangenen Turnieren immer wieder erlebt oder gehört von direkten Bekannten. Aber Schlussfolger ich dann richtig, dass die Vorfreude auf das Turnier schon vorhanden ist im Land?
Ja, es wird jedenfalls sichtbarer, so allmählich, so im Straßenbild. Weiß ich nicht. Du siehst jetzt von den großen russischen Sponsoren, dass sie anfangen, auch in ihrer Werbung mehr das Thema Fußball aufzugreifen. Oder egal, an welchem Flughafen du bist, da siehst du eigentlich inzwischen überall irgendwelche Banner mit den Logos. Hier in der Innenstadt nicht auf dem Roten Platz, sondern wenn man vor dem Roten Platz ein paar Schritte weitergeht, auf dem Manehschenplatz, da sind seit Dezember, ich glaube, das haben die kurz vor der Gruppenauslosung gemacht, stehen quasi als Modell die Umrisse aller Austragungsorte. Da steht eine große Statue vom Maskottchen. Genau, neulich war ich hier bei in so einer großen russischen Sportladenkette und inzwischen haben die eben auch zehn verschiedene Fußbälle mit dem Maskottchen drauf oder Skimützen, wo man dann auf seinem Kopf so einen Kopf von diesem Wolfsmaskottchen nochmal drauf hat, ne? Also es wird auf jeden Fall langsam sichtbarer.
Okay, na das ist doch interessant zu hören. Es gibt auch schon den offiziellen WM-Song. Wir beide haben ihn schon gehört.
Vor mir kommt jetzt noch Blut aus den Ohren.
Also wir haben schon im Vorgespräch darüber gesprochen, wie oft man den wohl hören wird, müssen, bis man ihn irgendwie erträgt. Also beim ersten Durchlauf tat es noch sehr weh, allerdings ist das bei fast allen WM-Songs so gewesen. Und ich meine, wir haben damals Herbert Grünemeyer ins Rennen geschickt. Warum sage ich heute eigentlich die ganze Zeit wir, wenn ich die Deutschen meine?
Ich weiß auch nicht. Möchtest du dich so ein bisschen abgrenzen, wenn du mit Russland sprichst?
Eigentlich ist das gar nicht so meins. Ein bisschen komisch. Ich deutsch-Tümmel heute an diesem Freitagvormittag ein bisschen. Keine Ahnung, wofür das jetzt spricht.
Ich habe gehört, ihr habt doch jetzt ein Heimatministerium. Vielleicht sind das die ersten Auswirkungen.
Ja, wobei Heimat ja eigentlich anders definiert ist im Koalitionsvertrag. Es ist ein Urban-Mist, dass es da tatsächlich um Heimat als Heimat geht. Eigentlich geht es um die Kommunen, aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, ein anderes Thema. Aber wenn wir eh schon über Politik sprechen, dann haben wir ja jetzt gerade auch eine verschärfte politische Situation zwischen England und Russland. Und diese Beziehung war auch fußballpolitisch nie die beste, denn wir erinnern uns, England hatte seinen Hut als Weltmeister-Austragungsort auch in den Ring geworfen und ist sowohl an Russland als auch an Katar gescheitert. Das ist jetzt noch sehr lange hin bis zur WM und wir alle wissen nicht, wie sich das entwickelt, aber hast du das Gefühl, das könnte sich auch auf das Turnier auswirken?
Das ist glaube ich jetzt schon echt fortgeschnittene Prognose, die du von mir erwartest. Also im Moment ist es natürlich extrem Konfrontation.
Also ich habe bei dir gelesen, dass die Engländer anstelle einer zwei Meter hohen Mauer rund um ihren Trainingsplatz eine sechs Meter hohe Mauer verlangen. Da habe ich mir schon die Frage gestellt, steht das in irgendeinem Verhältnis zu all den Dingen, die gerade zwischen England und Russland passieren und schon passiert sind, oder ist das Zufall?
Also wenn ich mich nicht komplett täusche, dann war diese Bauprojektnummer, bevor das gerade in der aktuellen Fall eskaliert war, ein paar Tage davor, das war glaube ich mehr so strategisch. Wir wollen nicht, dass uns einer beim Training zuschaut. Das ist trotzdem ungeschickt und schlecht kommuniziert. Aber das ist glaube ich auch was, das hätte jetzt auch, weiß ich nicht, die Fußballmannschaft von, ich weiß auch nicht, Deutschland, Argentinien, was weiß ich, Korea, sich wünschen können. Also das war, da war der Ton nicht, wir wollen uns abglänzen von den bösen Russen, sondern wir wollen in Ruhe trainieren, wir wollen keine Paparazzi, die über den Zaun fotografieren. Das ist die eine Seite. Die andere Seite ist, also natürlich ist es politisch, auf politischer Ebene gerade extrem gespannt auf Konfrontation. Es eskaliert eher, als dass es sich wieder ein kriegt. Das ist in diesen Tagen definitiv so. Andererseits...
Es ist ja auch noch sehr lange hin, bis wir...
Es ist ein Vierteljahr und es ist halt, also natürlich wird es bis dahin nicht wieder komplette Harmonie in den internationalen Beziehungen geben, aber es ist im Moment, finde ich, extrem schwer vorherzusagen, ob es heißt, in drei Monaten hat sich die Lage extrem verschärft oder hat sie sich etwas entspannt. Ich glaube, jeder, der behauptet, er könnte das im Moment vorhersagen, der blöft.
Okay, dann habe ich noch eine letzte Frage an dich, denn jetzt haben wir ja gerade auch schon ein großes Sportereignis hinter uns und auch da hat Russland wieder eine ganz besondere Rolle gespielt, nämlich die Olympischen Winterspiele. Und da habe ich sehr genau in der Berichterstattung drauf geachtet, wir haben deutsche Medien darüber berichtet, wie in den wenigen internationalen Medien, die ich gesehen habe, und auch wie wurde es in Russland rezipiert. Jetzt würde mich da aber, bevor ich da irgendwas Falsches sage, deine Meinung interessieren. Wie sind die Winterspiele in Russland wahrgenommen worden? Und wie war auch die Reaktion auf all das, was das IOC vor und nach den Winterspielen gemacht hat mit dem russischen Verband?
Also die Berichterstattung hat sich hier sehr auf die, natürlich auf die Erfolge der russischen Athleten, oder der Olympischen Athleten aus Russland konzentriert. Genau, das war halt natürlich, das sind die positiven Geschichten und das sind das, was du erzählt hast. Und klar kamen da sehr regelmäßig Leute zu Wort, die gesagt haben, das ist unfair, das ist pauschal, das wird den einzelnen Athleten nicht gerecht, aber es gab jetzt nicht hier, weiß ich nicht, wie du es gelesen hast, es gab jetzt nicht die komplette konfrontative Kante in der Berichterstattung, es ist alles ein großer olympischer Skandal. Wie hast du es denn wahrgenommen?
Na ja, ich fand es interessant, dass hierzulande sehr genau drauf geguckt wurde, wie dortzulande, über die olympischen Spiele berichtet wird und vor allem die Ankunft der russischen Athleten oder der olympischen Athleten aus Russland, wurde hier schon nochmal wiedergespiegelt in den Medien. Und das sah natürlich schon auch, ja das war sehr staatstragend, pathetisch, natürlich mit russischer Nationalhymne, das russische Eishockey-Team hat sich besondere Erwähnungen verdient, dadurch, dass es über die olympische Hymne, die gespielt wurde, anlässlich seiner Goldmedaille dann die russische Hymne gesungen hat. Und ich habe mir aber immer wieder die Frage gestellt, also zu dem ganzen Themenkomplex dieses Staatsdopings und wie das EOC sich dazu verhält, da habe ich eine sehr klare Meinung, die auch wesentlich dadurch geprägt ist, dass ich finde, wenn man sich diese Netflix-Doku Icarus, das Icarus-Projekt mal anguckt, dann kann man da, eigentlich gibt es dann keine zwei Meinungen mehr zu dieser Doping-Nummer, aber dass jetzt der russische Staat und auch, ja durchaus auch in einer Situation, in der es auch um eine Wahl geht, die jetzt dann in Kürze stattfindet, dass der das noch mal anders für sich nutzt und dass da dann das ganze Patriotismus-Programm aufgefahren wird, wenn die Athleten wieder zurückkommen in die Heimat, das finde ich weder besonders skandalös noch richtig überraschend und stellen wir sogar die Frage, ob es wirklich andere Länder anders gemacht hätten. Das ist doch, eigentlich liegt das doch nahe, das dann sogar noch für sich sogar positiv zu nutzen.
Also zwei Sachen. Das eine, was du gesagt hast, mit den Eishockeyspielern, die die Nationalhymne gesungen haben, da hatte ich zufällig russisches Radio gehört und der Kommentator hat das natürlich total gefeiert. Ah, und jetzt hört man unsere Hymne, hört mal die singen unsere Hymne, weil das natürlich eine große Baustelle ist, dass da nicht jeder in jedem Moment reflektiert, was da die Kausalkette hinter ist. Also warum darf da die Hymne nicht gespielt werden? Warum darf Russland da nicht als Land antreten? Das ist wahrscheinlich Alltag. Das andere ist, was du sagst zur Inszenierung. Also, große Inszenierungen sind hier tendenziell noch mal größer in so Sachen. Also wie wichtig hier das Land, die Hymne, die Fahne sind. Das ist natürlich ein ganz anderes Kaliber als in Deutschland. Das ist eher mit den USA vergleichbar. Das heißt, ich würde jetzt nicht an jeder einzelnen Inszenierung rumdeuteln wollen. Aber natürlich ist das was, woraus ein Land und damit auch seine Führung Bestätigung zieht. Das sind unsere Leute, die haben gut abgeschnitten. Das sind die bejubelten Helden, die zurückkommen. Das ist, wie du sagst, keine sehr ungewöhnliche Inszenierung.
Dann dürfen wir gespannt sein, wie die russische Nationalmannschaft sich rund um das Turnier inszeniert. Was auch passieren wird, sollte Russland dann doch nicht ganz überraschenderweise irgendwann ausscheiden. Und wenn es selbst vielleicht erst nach dem Achtelfinale ist. Aber ich bin mir sicher, das werden wir dann zu Genüge mitbekommen. Nicht zuletzt, weil wir wissen, wir können es bei dir nachlesen.
Das stimmt. Oder wir reden noch mal.
Oder, ja, das sogar natürlich am liebsten. Ich rede sehr gerne mit dir.
Gleichfalls, das hat Spaß gemacht.
Danke, das freut mich sehr, Katrin. Katrin Scheib war das, Journalistin, die in Russland lebt und auf NTV über die WM berichtet, einen Newsletter hat, Russball, und auf Twitter, etkascheib heißt, und ich empfehle allen Hörern und Hörern da draußen, folg Katrin. Katrin, vielen Dank dir, dass du dir mal wieder die Zeit genommen hast. Ja, tschüss. Bis bald mal wieder. Und ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, seid gedankt für alle eure Unterstützung. Wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das tun unter rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Und finanziert damit unter anderem solche Kurzpässe wie diesen hier aufgenommen an einem nebligen Giesinger Freitagvormittag. Und in diesem Sinne wünsche ich euch eine gute Woche, bis zum nächsten Kurzpass, ciao!